[Musique]
c'est au ravin bleu barré celle de
concerts à versailles que se tiendra une
soirée en l'honneur de georges brassens
samedi 6 novembre 2021 marque le
centenaire de sa naissance l'association
écrire à versailles qui regroupe des
écrivains locaux organisé un concours
pour mettre en avant les textes de
georges brassens les participants sur un
air de l'artiste devait écrire de
nouveau texte on ait eu 80 participants
et on a été étonné par la qualité des
réponses que nous avons reçues bassens
disait que faire une chanson c'est
simple et compliqué il faut mettre
quelques mots les bons mots sur les
bonnes notes mais lauréats vont êtres
vont pouvoir
se présenter chanter après il y a il ya
un concert un chanteur yvelinois viendra
interpréter aussi les chansons peu
connues de georges brassens il ya des
tas de
deux chansons
tout à fait admirable qui mettrait connu
que je n'interpréterais pas je préfère
les fuites les petites sept petites
perles méconnues comme la comme le
verger du roi louis ou
la rose la bouteille et la poignée de
main qui ne posent pas souvent radio
show que c'est dommage auteur
compositeur et interprète georges
brassens a vécu de 1958 à 1971 dans les
yvelines il a habité au moulin de la
bombe au bord du ru de galli a créé
pierre ces mêmes cet endroit qui lui a
inspiré la chanson auprès de mon arbre
auprès de mon ami départ
l'incroyable des mélodies absolument
fantastique il est totalement méconnu
mais comme mélodiste que musicien était
vraiment très fort et franchement il ya
une une plénitude à
l'interpréter que je retrouve avec aucun
autre
chanteur c'est d'écrire des paroles
depuis mes plus jeunes années et c'est
vrai que c'est pour moi l'exemple absolu
la référence total
le maître charge brassant sa mise en
musique plus d'une centaine de textes
écrits il a sorti 14 albums studio de
1952 à 1976
[Musique]